foreign
she was simply the best tributes to the
legendary Tina Turner
[Music]
the queen of rock and roll's influence
on music
and how she overcame abuse and inspired
Millions
also on this Wednesday night Canadians
sinking deeper into debt the new warning
from the country's housing agency and
the advice to people struggling to pay
the bills
Florida's governor enters the race for
the White House his unconventional
declaration
and life returns to normal for some
albertans that's awesome why not all
fire evacuees are eager to go back home
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin with sad news about singer Tina
Turner who has died at the age of 83
after a long illness she started
performing as a teenager and was still a
superstar decades later belting out one
rock and roll hit after another
[Music]
at age 60 Turner became the biggest
selling concert artist in the world her
high energy uninhibited style earning
her the title of queen of rock and roll
and inspiring the next generation of
artists
[Music]
Turner did not sail easily into Fame she
spent years in an abusive relationship
with her first husband Ike finally
escaping it and finding even greater
success as a solo artist proving she
could hold her own against any man Mike
troulet looks at her extraordinary life
[Applause]
Live Aid was less a duet for Tina Turner
as it was a coronation
it's been a rock and roll Pioneer in the
60s whose star began to fade in the 70s
but when she took the stage with Mick
Jagger in 1985 there was no question
Tina Turner was the Undisputed queen of
rock Tina Turner will go down in history
as one of the most badass singers in the
history of rock there was no one like
her and there won't be anybody like her
ever again
[Music]
Ike and Tina Turner seemed to have it
all Tina with all that frenetic energy
drove their band to stardom at home life
with the controlling and abusive Ike was
dramatically different and you left me
on the Highway by the time she gone up
the courage to ask for a divorce she
only wanted one thing her name which I
could trademark as a way of controlling
her there were three things that were
valuable to Tina Turner one was that
raspy voice that nobody else had second
were her legs which she had insured for
3.2 million dollars and the third was
that name Tina Turner the one that Ike
gave her and in order to get out from
underneath his thumb when she went solo
she had to give up everything that she
had earned to that point
so she could get away from Mike she left
with 36 Cents in her pocket but she was
free musically she struggled as a solo
artist until 1984 when she reinvented
herself as a star on MTV
[Music]
by the time she appeared in the movie
Mad Max she was Unstoppable
Buster deal face the wheel her life was
turned into a biopic a musical and a
best-selling memoir
I had an abusive life
there's no other way to tell the story
by not shying away from her past she
became an inspiration to female artists
everywhere
amazing I went in the room and I just
you know I walked because I couldn't
believe it really she was the queen of
rock and roll high heels big hair and an
even bigger voice Tina Turner made it
look easy even when life was hard
microlife Global News
Turner's representative says she died
peacefully at her home near Zurich
Switzerland after a long illness she
leaves us all her greatest work her
music
now to other news there is a new warning
about how much debt Canadians are
carrying and High house prices are
largely to blame according to the Canada
mortgage and housing corporation Canada
now has the highest level of household
debt in the G7 and mortgages make up
about three quarters of that debt Rising
interest rates only add to the burden of
those struggling to pay bills and as
Eric Sorensen reports it also makes
Canada vulnerable to a global economic
crisis
even as housing prices Skyrocket across
the country Canadians are looking for
ways to take on the debt necessary to
own a home mortgages make up the Lion's
Share of Canadians household debt and
it's only getting harder to finance I
have noticed a big difference in
um I used to see a lot more friends
purchasing homes it's pretty pretty rare
now Kate madower is a nurse I'm a single
income right now so I'm just doing my
little rent right now and putting money
aside but that has become more
challenging the problem Canada's
population growth has made housing more
scarce and unaffordable there's a lot of
that going into buying housing and
that's because there's not a lot of
housing available so we need a drastic
dramatic increase in housing Supply in
order to try and address this people are
just paying too much for housing
Canadians capacity and willingness to
finance debt is almost unparalleled
among G7 countries as far back as 2010
Canada had the greatest household debt
95 percent as a share of GDP by 20 21
household debt for some countries has
climbed though for those closest to
Canada's levels the U.S and the UK the
percentage has dropped yet in Canada the
numbers have shot up to 107 percent as a
share of GDP in other words Canada's
household debt is greater than the size
of the country's entire economy and with
the sharp rise in interest rates
Canadians are facing even higher levels
of debt they benefited for a long period
of time from very low interest rates
without having taken this sort of hit to
their balance sheet but now they're
feeling the impact of those that decade
and a half of debt accumulation now
coming up against higher interest rates
and the impact that's having on their
household budgets next imagine if
there's a global downturn in the economy
not something cmhc is predicting but
many Canadians are ill-prepared to pay
their debts if they lose their jobs if
the economy goes south handling or
paying off all of this data is going to
be extremely painful and will be a a
severe problem for the Canadian econ
how to deal with mounting debt I would
say definitely being more strict in like
budgeting so minimize spending and maybe
hold on to your money for now says Cole
knocker someone who's looking to save
for a house honest to God wait I would
just wait Eric Sorensen Global News
Toronto
with just days to go before Alberta
chooses its next government a
controversial figure is taking aim at
Premier and United conservative party
leader Danielle Smith preacher Arthur
pawlowski who was found guilty of
Mischief for encouraging truckers at the
Coots border blockade held a press
conference today on the steps of the
legislature to denounce Smith
this person is not representing our
values she's not conservative
she is as liberal and NDP as you can be
the nature of his relationship with
Smith was called into question when a
phone call between the two was made
public in March Polaski and the premier
discussed the covid-19 charges he was
facing and late last week Smith was
found guilty of violating conflict of
interest rules in relation to that phone
call it's just one twist in an election
campaign that Smith's NDP opponent says
is all about trust Heather urich's West
is with me from Calgary Heather is this
likely to sway voters who support the
UCP
well Donna polowski may have been part
of the group that helped Danielle Smith
narrowly win the UCP leadership with
promises for amnesty for covet violators
and rights protections for those opposed
to vaccines but he's not speaking for
the majority of her longtime supporters
in denouncing her today take back
Alberta leaders say he doesn't speak for
them albertans however may still have
questions about judgment why Smith took
his phone call or spoke to the Justice
Minister on pawlowski's behalf in the
first place and it's fair to wonder how
much this latest strange twist will move
undecided voters
it is simply wild that this is all
circulating in the middle of an election
campaign and while it has made a
difference uh that's why the election is
closed it doesn't appear to be
disqualified
now there is no denying there is a
lingering hangover from the pandemic
among many people in this province and
not just from those angry about
restrictions the Health Care System
spent years under siege and that's made
the future of Health Care the number one
ballot issue heading into voting day
Public Health Care and force you to pay
to see a doctor in a province where
politics was once about Pipelines
I believe no one should ever have to pay
out of pocket to see a family doctor
Health Care Now Reigns Supreme and
post-pandemic things are a mess three
years I've been on a list we're even
getting to a point now where emergency
rooms are closing we have one
obstetrician in gynecologists in
Lethbridge it was getting to the point
where it was dangerous for me to drive
problems with Health Care aren't
Alberta's alone but within the province
the coveted years saw plenty of acrimony
between health care workers and the
Jason Kenney UCP that conflict has had
consequences data from
the Canadian Institute for health
information kaha shows that we lost more
Family Physicians to net migration out
than any other province in 2022
Alberta's next government will need to
bring those doctors back while working
to address a backlog of deferred care
the pain was excruciating Calgary stage
actress Catherine curbis had been
waiting for a hip replacement for nearly
two years when a surgeon told her she'd
have to wait at least one year more my
husband immediately started looking at
private surgeries because he he knew how
much pain I was in all the time so in
March curb has paid out of pocket to
have her surgery in Toronto according to
the Canadian Institute of Health
Information albertans had some of the
longest weights for hip and knee surgery
in 2022 in January the United
conservative party unveiled a plan to
contract thousands of Orthopedic
procedures each year to a private
surgical facility though kaihai says the
impact of this move is not yet known a
lot of the contracts have just most
recently been signed so it will be
interesting to see its impact on both
the weights and the numbers of people
waiting for surgery the Alberta NDP
meanwhile says it will address surgical
wait times by expanding access solely
within the public system two parties our
UCP team is improving Health Care with
two different plans our Alberta NDP will
fix Health Care question for voters who
to believe Heather your ex West Global
News Calgary
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis a man
Danielle Smith has called a hero is
officially in he has filed paperwork to
enter the 2024 presidential race and
he's about to go public with it on a
Twitter live stream with its billionaire
owner Elon Musk it is an unusual way to
make the announcement but Twitter is
what Donald Trump used to Rally his base
Jackson prosco reports
I'm Ron DeSantis and I'm running for
president to lead our Great American
comeback it's no surprise Florida's
governor wound up here Ron DeSantis has
spent years eyeing a much higher office
I am not doing polls to tell me what to
do or what to think but to get to the
White House DeSantis will first have to
get past Donald Trump's iron grip on the
Republican Party selling himself As
Trump without the baggage I think the
party has developed a culture of losing
he needs to sort of say here is a flavor
you haven't tried but I'm gonna be
better and more satisfying in the long
run than Donald Trump and I can actually
win the White House DeSantis has branded
himself the ultimate culture Warrior
passing anti-gay anti-transgender and
anti-abortion laws in Florida the state
of Florida is where woke goes to die
while picking a fight with Disney the
biggest tourist draw in his State the
DeSantis has touched some hot button
cultural issues but it looks to me like
you need to touch some of the cultural
issues in order to be able to win over
the Republican electorate these days
winning over American voters will be
tougher stay tuned opponents have
branded him an authoritarian well
DeSantis is staying sheltered with a
small base launching his campaign via
Twitter instead of a rally he wants to
show that he's going to do something
different because in the primary he's
running against predominantly an 80 year
old man should he make it through the
primaries predominantly running against
an 80 year old man DeSantis and the
other Republican contenders may not be
banking on running a sustained campaign
against former president Trump instead
they're likely positioning themselves to
stand in should Trump's campaign be
sidelined by legal woes in that scenario
DeSantis would quickly become the front
runner for now he still faces a very
long and tough climb to the top
Donna Jackson prosco in Washington
tonight thanks Jackson coming up why
some of Canada's opposition party
leaders are rejecting an offer to view
classified intelligence
the Canadian government and Saudi Arabia
have appointed new ambassadors the first
step towards restoring full diplomatic
ties and ending nearly five years of
strained relations prime minister Justin
Trudeau met with the Saudi Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman on the sidelines of
the Apec Summit in Bangkok last November
their spat dates back to 2018 when Saudi
Arabia recalled its Ambassador and
restricted trade after the Canadian
Embassy in Riyadh tweeted that Saudi
Arabia should release women's rights
activists being detained in the Kingdom
the release yesterday of a report into
foreign interference in Canada is not
putting the issue to rest for prime
minister Justin Trudeau opposition
leaders are rejecting the former
Governor General David Johnston's
recommendations yesterday he said no to
a public inquiry and called on political
leaders to unite on the issue as our
chief political correspondent David
Aiken explains that report has only
pushed the Prime Minister and his
opponents farther apart
we have offered to the leaders of all
the parties in the house the capacity to
get the security clearances necessary so
that they can look at that raw
intelligence themselves it was David
Johnson's idea and one enthusiastically
endorsed by Justin Trudeau give
opposition leaders the same Secrets
Johnston based his report on one
opposition leader is in I will be
receiving the top secret clearance to
understand get the same information that
Mr Johnson received I think that is what
a responsible leader of an opposition
party would do and I will be doing that
the other two are out it's a dumb trap
it's for those who are not very careful
they want to say
we offered you to see everything you saw
everything you cannot say a word this is
a secret we're not going to allow the
government to silence leaders of the
opposition
by swearing them to secrecy
on this matter of grave public
importance Trudeau says the conservative
leader is being irresponsible poliev is
choosing to sit behind a veil of
ignorance instead he doesn't want the
facts to get in the way of a good
political argument or a personal attack
meanwhile the government of China is
watching all this Beijing officials said
Chinese interference in Canada's Affairs
is a quote fabrication intended to smear
China and the Canadians should just stop
talking about it quote just put an end
to actions and words tarnishing China's
image Donna okay David Aiken thank you
superstorm next to Typhoon sweeps its
way through Guam
[Music]
this is the first glimpse of the damage
on Guam after it was hit by a super
typhoon the category 4 storm slammed
into the U.S territory's Northern tip
pummeling the Western Pacific island
winds reached 225 kilometers an hour
there is torrential rain and huge storm
surges Guam's Governor is urging the
islands 150 000 residents to remain
indoors the typhoon is the strongest
storm to hit the U.S territory in
decades and it sat over the island for
more than 12 hours downed trees are
everywhere and there are fears of
landslides and flash flooding in the UK
a woman has died two weeks after being
struck by a royal motorcade in London 81
year old Helen Holland was visiting her
sister on May 10 when she was hit by a
police motorcycle escorting Sophie The
Duchess of Edinburgh the sister-in-law
of King Charles a statement from
Buckingham Palace says Sophie is deeply
saddened by the news of Holland's death
[Music]
sweet home next the emotional return for
Fox Creek residents
hello
they say home is where the heart is and
for some Alberta residents that's taking
on a deeper meaning rain and cooler
temperatures have slowed the Wildfire
activity enough for people from Fox
Creek to go home there is a lingering
risk of a flare-up but for now most are
enjoying a sense of relief and gratitude
nitu garcha reports on the emotional
homecoming
returning residents in Fox Creek are
getting a literal breath of fresh air
the Thick Smoke and Haze that have
blanketed the area for weeks is gone so
is the immediate threat from two
wildfires burning nearby it's just nice
to see people get back and you know a
lot of thumbs up and it's just awesome
for firefighter Wade Martino it's an
emotional moment of reflection on what
it took to get to this point
Long Haul right and uh
you know my house was in the line of
fire too and it was uh it was
sprinklered and you know there was
mornings didn't know if we were going to
be going home to uh to a house Martino
his wife and their son all volunteered
together it's been a long haul a lot of
hard work and to be able to serve
with my family
we're out their family has lived in this
community for decades they say they're
thankful for all the support their
members have received from out of town
Crews supporting the fire fight those
boys really stepped up and yeah we give
us a fighting chance to fight off the
swap yeah the lady's cooking for us the
ladies the the square meals a day
in White Court where evacuees have been
staying there's gratitude for the
hospitality over nearly three weeks and
joy over being able to return home
what's your reaction to that so happy I
know there's a lot of cleaning but it's
so so excited to come home guess what
I'm going home
it's hearing that news that I feel
really great not everyone is rushing
back and those who are know to be on
alert good feeling that we can go home
the question is should we like that's
why I look at it because there's still
two fires burned out of control so I can
foresee you next week that uh
you know we're on evacuation alerts and
and you have to pick up the pieces and
go again we do remain on a four hour
evacuation notice there are still two
active wildfires you know quite close to
our community with essential Services up
and running there's relief and rejoicing
[Music]
as they get a short reprieve from a long
fire fight likely to last through the
summer
Global News Fox Creek Alberta
and that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen